any schoolboy Chuy's what you can be
sure of is that we will overcome this
difficult period we'll find a way out of
this difficult situation I'm sure we
will be stronger in the international
arena and the global economy
how long will this take in the worst
possible scenario it will take around
two years
I repeat though after this growth is
inevitable and this is also because the
external economic factors will change
the growth of the International economy
will require further energetic resources
there are questions to both the
government and the central bank about
the timeliness and quality of the
decisions that have been taken but
overall their actions are both suitable
and correct now we are witnessing the
falling down of oil prices there are
many discussions on that topic why is it
happening whether there is a conspiracy
between Saudi Arabia and the United
States in order to punish Iran and
influence the economy of Russia and
Venezuela
etc there might be maybe not a friend of
mine a dignitary from Europe recently
told me do you have love what do you
mean I asked you love someone yes I do
is there anyone that loves you yes
people love me everything is just fine
don't worry
did you just go in it no duh